Speaker 1: Why don't we hear next from how
about Mario in Turkey? Mario, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Oh, hey. Hey,
can you hear me? Yes, I can.
I'm actually I'm from the United States
and I'm deployed in Turkey right now, but
I was just going to say, I really don't really
have a question, but it's I never really thought
that I was going to be called on. I just want to
say it was you for about five years and remember
for about five years now. And I think you're
doing absolutely wonderful work and keep it up.
Speaker 1: Thank you. I appreciate
the kind words and the support.
Yeah. Can you tell us what you're up to, what are
you doing in Turkey? Can you tell us anything?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I, for example, I fix planes, I
work as an electrician for a KC 135. There's a big
tanker tanker jet, so it's like if it's if
Speaker 1: it's not classified, what's like
a typical electrical problem on
a KC 135 that you'd have to fix?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I don't know if I can really
say that. Oh, wow. Even even even what the
Speaker 1: problems are is potentially classified.
Speaker 3: I mean, it's I mean, you know,
it's just, yeah, everything that we work on.
It's not like it's not like a super big deal,
because, I mean, Turkey has the same answer,
like, I don't know for sure so. Wow. I just
rather I'd just rather not, you know, let me
Speaker 1: put it this way. Let me ask a
different question if you can answer this
one. Does being a regular home electrician
transfer in any way to being an electrician
for airplanes as a general question?
Speaker 3: As a general question, I'd say I don't
I don't have any experience in that, but I mean,
a ground is solid ground and, you know, actually
getting power to a component. You still, you know,
like that component should be working, right?
Speaker 1: Got it. And being being deployed
in Turkey is your is your time spent
like basically on a base or are you
out in the communities at all?
Speaker 3: Oh, yeah, where's my?
I haven't been off the base since I got here, and
I've been here for almost two months now, so they
don't they don't let us because just because the
proximity of the enemies in the area, they say,
I don't know how true it is, but they say, you
know, it was like terrorists out here. And I'm
sure there's probably people that don't like
us. But you know, I think from their standpoint,
it's is better safe than sorry.
Speaker 1: Wow. So you
literally do not leave the base.
Speaker 3: I haven't left the base in two months,
and now they don't. Yeah, they do. They can.
Speaker 1: You can you even get like,
will they bring in local pistachio baklava
for you or you're not even able to get that?
Speaker 3: Oh yeah, no. Yeah, we have like the
locals, like they have their their businesses
out here and on base. So it's like. But I mean,
I guess I've talked to some of the locals before,
and then they say that their food is like
Americanized so that we can, you know,
I've been sarcastic. I said, that kind of sucks,
you know, because I kind of want, you know,
I want to try traditional food. Yes, not exactly.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I gotcha. All right, my friend.
Thank you for the call. I appreciate
it. Yeah, thanks. Keep it up. All right,
thank you. There is Mario from Turkey. You can
get Turkish pistachio baklava on the base. Really,
really important issue, which I'm glad we were
able to get to the bottom of. That's going to do
it for today. Thanks to everybody who called in.
Apologies. I was not able to get to everybody,
but we'll take calls again. We will. We will
do it again if I have anything to say about it.